ja ob jetzt Jamaika oder ich glaube eher
die Ampel auf jeden Fall gibt es ein
Thema was nicht nur mich umtreibt was
viele viele Millionen Bürgerinnen und
Bürger umtreibt in diesem Land wir sehen
hier das Bild einer Tankstelle aus
Berlin die heute erstmals 2 € für den
Liter Sprit verlangt hat zugegeben da
ging es ein bisschen um Champagner
Benzin das ist also ein besonders edles
gewesen aber wir haben auch die anderen
Anzeigen gesehen der Liter Diesel fast
160 und Super Benzin oder E10 bei über
1,70 € aber benzin ist nicht das einzige
was in diesem Monaten und Wochen
besonders teuer geworden ist es geht
auch um Gas es geht um Heizöl aber auch
das tägliche Einkaufen 4,1 Prozent das
ist die Inflationsrate im September
gewesen und es gibt Experten die sogar
für die nächsten Monate bis zu 5%
Inflation Voraussagen den höchsten Wert
seit 28 Jahren und es wird mutmaßlich
nicht besser wenn wir uns anschauen was
an co2-umlagen auf gerade Energieträger
wie Öl und Gas nach oben drauf kommt
dann wird auch das nächste das
übernächste und das über übernächste
Jahr noch teurer bedeutet die nächste
Bundesregierung ist gefordert und was
mich besonders stört ist eigentlich dass
die Regierung bisher beim Thema
Inflation sich eher wegduckt als
aufschreibt kein Wunder denn sie
verdient kräftig mit beispielsweise über
die Mehrwertsteuer beim Mieter Benzin
fließen mittlerweile 90 cent des Preises
in die Taschen des Finanzministers und
des Staates also die nächste
Bundesregierung mutmaßlich eine von SPD
grün und FDP geführt muss ein
Stoppschild setzen für Inflation da wo
etwas teurer wird da muss sie auf der
anderen Seite entlasten beispielsweise
Steuern senken und wo sich Kosten gar
nicht vermeiden lassen wie gesagt müssen
Bürger entlastet werden anders geht es
nicht sonst droht hier sozialer
Unfrieden die Inflation wird zum
Stresstest für die neue ampelwerten da
bin ich fest überzeugt davon weil das
nicht aufgeht
klimainvestitionen Steuerentlastung und
noch darauf schauen dass die Preise
stabil bleiben viele Leute werden nach
diesem Winter ruiniert werden wenn die
Gaspreise so ansteigen wenn die Benzin
und diese Preise so einsteigen dann wird
bei vielen am Ende des Monats nichts
mehr im Portemonnaie übrig bleiben und
dann gehen Investition zurück der geht
Inlandskonsum zurück und hat das
Auswirkungen auf unsere Wirtschaft
deswegen muss die Politik sich dieses
Themas annehmen muss gegensteuern das
ich sehe das genau wie sie und jede
Regierung die jetzt ins Amt kommt hat
das als erste Hausaufgabe zu erledigen
wir haben Sie eigentlich mit einer
wahren inflations Heuchelei zu tun muss
man sagen auf der einen Seite verdient
der Staat über die Mehrwertsteuer
kräftig mit auf der anderen Seite ist ja
auch Preistreiber wir sehen das beim
Bauen beispielsweise durch immer härtere
Vorschriften wir sehen es aber auch
gerade beim Thema Energie durch diese
co2-umlage die drauf kommt und da ist
das ein bisschen wedeln und sagen ja wir
wissen um die Sorgen der Menschen das
ist scheinheilig das ist nicht echt
gerade weil der Stadt Preistreiber auf
der einen Seite ist und auf der anderen
Seite kräftig mit verdienen und kassiert
ja ist ja nicht nur Preistreiber ist ja
auch regelgeber wenn ich mal an die
Leute im diesem Land denke die auf dem
Dorf wohnen die sollen keine Ölheizung
mehr haben Gas wird immer teurer Holz
sollen sie auch nicht verheizen wegen
dem CO2-Fußabdruck und
PV-Anlage können die meisten sich nicht
leisten und dann stehen sie da an fragen
sich im Winter wie kriege ich eigentlich
mein Haus noch warm und dass diese Sorge
um drei viele und es hat auch bei der
Bundestagswahl eine Rolle gespielt
gerade in solchen Regionen dass die
Leute sich gefragt haben wo es
eigentlich der Weg wo die Politik mir
hilft dass ich diesen Weg gehen kann
dass wir eine klimaneutrales Land kommen
dass ich mir das aber auch leisten kann
und die Sorge spätestens einer
Tankstelle war sie begründet vor der
Wahl als die Preise erstmals dann
richtig hochgeschwappt sind das sind
viele schockiert zurückgeblieben wann
haben Sie das letzte Mal gemerkt dass es
richtig teuer geworden ist also ich weiß
kurz vor Weihnachten habe ich vor glaube
ich weniger als 1 Euro
gestern habe ich
1,55 bezahlt für einen Liter Diesel und
ich bin angewiesen auf das Auto wie
viele Menschen das ist kein Luxusprodukt
die man irgendwie jetzt mit dem Fahrrad
kann das ist auch Freiheit und das sind
Themen die auch vor den Wahlen da waren
da hat man sie unter Druck man wollte
nicht darüber reden schon vor den Wahlen
wusste man dass viele Leute nicht mal
Heizung leisten können diesem Winter und
sie reden ja über die über die
Wirtschaft die Wirtschaft ist indirekt
betroffen weil ja die Einzelpersonen
nicht mal das Geld haben um ein
einkaufen zu gehen aber es trifft auch
die unsere wir unseren Standort
Deutschland alles wirtschaftsort dass
die Firmen nicht mehr weltweit
konkurrenzfähig sind wenn sie so viel
vor Energie bezahlen können und das ist
natürlich Fragen die jeder Bürger und
Bürger in diesem Land beschäftigen und
beschäftigen werden ja ich habe in
meinen Wahlkreis Unternehmen die sind in
der energieintensiv gibt es eine Waffe
Bäckerei felinchen wäre das vielleicht
kennt das Leute die auf ihrer Ernährung
achten die dem das Produkt ganz gerne
und kaufen das ein und da ist es so dass
die ein Drittel der Kosten sind nur
Gaskosten weil die Waffeln ja gebacken
werden müssen und der Unternehmer sagt
ganz klar irgendwann kann ich mir das
leisten weil ich kann an diesem Preis ja
nicht steuern ich kann da nicht drehen
wir haben hat vielleicht die Union auch
ein bisschen dahin gehen auch vor den
Grünen und vor diesem Klimawandel waren
auch ein bisschen gekuscht nein die
Union ist glaube ich die einzige Partei
im politischen Spektrum die deutlich
sagt wir müssen beides miteinander in
Verbindung bringen es muss möglich sein
das stimmt okay aber die sind ein Stück
kleiner aber eine Temperatur
verbinden so verbinden dass man nicht
mehr Sprit leisten kann nein eben nicht
es muss ihm beides möglich das muss
leistbar bleiben trotzdem immer die
Klimaziele erreichen deswegen muss man
manche Schritte auch langsamer gehen das
ist eben das entscheidende dass man es
machen muss ist es gibt nicht wie bei
der Meinungsbildung vor allem dieses
schwarze oder weiß es muss auch eine
Möglichkeit geben dass man diesen Weg so
geht dass man die Leute mitnimmt und
nicht zurück lässt und wenn Verständnis
kriegen wir doch nur für politische
Entscheidungen mit die Leute es
nachvollziehen können wenn Sie das für
sich auch akzeptieren können dass es zu
ihrem Leben gehört und wenn die Gefühl
ist in Berlin wird das entschieden was
eine Lebenswirklichkeit zu Hause vorbei
geht dann wenden sie sich ab und dann
haben wir genau das Wahlverhalten was
man auch gerade in den neuen Ländern ein
bisschen sieht das denn ist es
Autofreiheit oder muss man vielleicht
auch persönliche Freiheiten müssen
zurücknehmen um dem Klimawandel zu
begegnen ich glaube dass das
hippe-debatten sind die wir hier in
einer riesigen Stadt führen in der ich
aus dem Haus gehen kann und fale in eine
U-Bahn oder in eine S-Bahn in was auch
immer zwei Drittel der Deutschen leben
aber überhaupt gar nicht in der Stadt
sondern leben auf dem Land für die sind
weder die hippen lastenraddebatten weil
sie die
50 km zum nächsten Bäcker der schon ins
nächste Zentrum mitgezogen ist überhaupt
gar nicht mehr fahren können weil dort
alte Leute leben für die sind
lastenraddebatten einfach auch nicht und
die Frage ob sie ein Bus nehmen die
stellt sich auch nicht weil dort schon
seit Jahren keiner mehr fährt mit dieser
kaputten Infrastruktur die haben einfach
nur ein Auto und da geht das gar nicht
um Freiheit sondern da geht es um die
elementare Frage wie komme ich an mein
nächstes Brot und da ist alles was wir
hier besprechen die wir sofort in nehme
ich jetzt die Busse oder die Bahn das
erreicht die nicht Carsharing
bin ja über das Problem vielleicht kann
man noch mal vielleicht kann man einen
den Punkt noch ein bisschen weiten den
wir machen wir erleben natürlich auch
jetzt und wir wissen alle Inflation wird
am Ende zumindest teilweise gestoppt
durch eine Zinspolitik wenn die Preise
steigen dann muss normalerweise die
Notenbank die Zinsen erhöhen um diesen
Preisschub zu dämpfen diesen unsozialen
Preisschub also Inflation ist unsozial
und die Notenbank steuert dagegen das
tut die Notenbank nicht obwohl sie als
eigentlich machen müsste wir haben ja
auch auf europäischer Ebene eine
Inflation die deutlich zu hoch ist es
tut sie nicht warum tut sie das nicht
wir erleben jetzt die Quittung für die
Schuldenpolitik der letzten Jahre denn
viele viele Regierungen haben sich auch
nach der Eurokrise massiv verschuldet
haben sich Staatsanleihen ausgegeben die
hat die Notenbank gekauft das Problem
ist jetzt sie sind massiv verschuldet
wenn jetzt die Zinsen leicht steigen
würden müssten diese Regierung
beispielsweise in Italien plötzlich
ihren Haushalt schrumpfen könnten
weniger ausgeben weil sie plötzlich mehr
wieder für die Zinsen ausgeben müssten
also hätten weniger zur Verfügung für
Sozialleistungen für wie auch immer die
Regierung haben sich selbst in eine
Situation manövriert und die Bürgerinnen
und Bürger zahlen dafür jetzt die Kosten
über hohe Inflation die nicht gestoppt
wird durch die Notenbank das ist eine
ganz ganz bittere Quittung die jetzt
zehn Jahre nach Ausbruch der Finanzkrise
und Eurokrise jetzt zu schultern ist
absolut weil neue Investitionen dazu
kommt gerade in klimainvestitionen weil
genau das Thema was man davon hatten
deswegen muss eine neue Koalition oft
darauf achten dass sie die Fiskalpolitik
des Staates im Griff behält und sagt
nicht weiter ausufern lässt sonst trifft
uns das mega hart für die nächsten
Generation
in diesen Tagen er ist der zuständige
Finanzminister ich würde mir ein
stärkeres Wort wünschen ich will mal ein
Beispiel nennen wo ich mir auch wünschen
würde dass sie Verantwortlichen die in
die Ampel gehen wollen ihre Meinung
sagen wenn wir über die Preise an der
Tankstelle diskutieren warum wird dann
hingenommen dass die Deutsche Bahn ihre
Preise jetzt erhöhen will wenn ich eine
Alternative schaffen will wenn ich
Mobilität verändern will dort wo sie
möglich ist dann muss ich auch darauf
achten dass ich auch die Preisgestaltung
so mache dass ich das Angebot nicht weg
inflationäre und das tut die Deutsche
Bahn gerade jeder der umsteigen will hat
keine Alternative genau
für Stammkunden die Bahncard wird ja
teurer das wird ja nicht so Sachen die
Leute die schon umgestiegen sind die
kriegen jetzt ist ganz dicke erstmal
noch mal obendrauf
würde oder Verkehrsminister Bahntickets
nur noch halb so teuer Bahncard
ebenfalls halb so teuer ja definitiv
ÖPNV genauso sind eine Frage ich muss
doch Mobilität erstmal attraktiv machen
und das fängt an mit besseren
Verbindungen das fängt an dass sie
überhaupt Verbindung gibt vom Dorf in
die Stadt das Mobilität möglich ist dann
kann ich das die alternativen machen die
Politik bespricht das immer runter Ring
darum sie haben es genau gesagt wir
reden erst für die Frage wie mache ich
die Benzinpreise teurer wie verbinde ich
das Auto fahren wie schaffe ich
Parkplätze für Lastenfahrräder aber
nicht mehr für Autos die mache ich die
Innenstädte wie blockiere ich die aber
ich schaffe keine Alternativen hier in
Berlin ist das alles leicht gesagt wer
draußen auf dem Land ist sieht wie die
Lebenswirklichkeit
[Musik]